[Music]
I think as you move to the upper ranks
of science ranks being positions of
influence and access you see fewer
female faces and I think the basic
reason is the same reason that you don't
see a lot of female faces in Congress or
on the Supreme Court or on the directing
board of Fortune 500 companies I mean I
think there are fundamental power
imbalances between the sexes that play
themselves out in society and I think
science is just not immune to that which
actually isn't a very controversial
stance if you think about it
science is performed by people and it's
subject to all the various foibles that
plague the rest of our social dynamics
you know believe it or not I don't have
very controversial views on the subject
I always go back to basic questions we
asked about women's labor because
working in science is performing labor
and performing it as a woman is women's
labor and one of the very first
questions we always ask about women's
labor is is it safe and so I've spoken
about how women laboring in the science
are not working in safe spaces all of
the time
that's just question number one you know
are we safe while we're trying to learn
are we safe while we're trying to work
there are a few things about science
that are special women live in a world
where we are forced to consider our
safety at every turn
you know we minimize risk while we
maximize activity it's this constant
balancing act that we do
now in science we go we also go to
unfamiliar places and we do things that
haven't been done before and we work
alone in buildings late at night and we
move through groups of people that are
largely dominated by men and all of
those things present special
consideration for the safety of women's
spaces so I think there are some
specific things in science that come
into play
I think step number two after we asked
whether women are safe is what are the
legal protections that are in place what
are the institutional and civil
protections in place to defend women's
safety within their workspaces
I think young women often don't know
what the sexual harassment policy is at
their University or is at their place of
work they may not know the details of
title 9 how title 9 protects their
educational experience I would say that
learning those details and considering
what recourse might be is a useful
exercise it's probably more useful than
some kind of seminar that advises you on
how to modify your behavior so that
you're less likely to provoke harassing
behavior or something like that you know
learn what the regulations and laws are
that protect you so that if you have to
you can make difficult choices with
awareness I think that's the responsible
advice to give women as they start to
labor within these spaces
I really do we are more open about
sexual harassment and sexual assault
than we used to be and I think that can
be regarded as a victory in its own
right
I think combating isolation around
these issues is important and I think
the internet for example has connected
women in ways which they weren't
connected before and so it's become a
critical tool in allowing for the
informal communication that facilitates
behavior that's not formalized because
it's officially in theory wrong or
condemned etc but I think we have to be
very explicit that that's what we're
doing and that combating isolation is
not the same as delivering justice and
we went through a period where these
sexual harassment cases at well-known
universities were very very much in the
news and all kinds of opinions were
coming out on it and I became
uncomfortable with the idea that somehow
just talking about it was this massive
step forward now talking about it is
important and I wouldn't have you know
I'm on the front lines I am talking
about it so it's not like I don't
believe in that approach but it felt
more and more felt the need to say
listen the talking only goes so far and
if you look at that article the
criticism isn't directed at the women
who put up with this stuff the criticism
is not even directed at the men who
perpetrate it the criticism is directed
at our institutions that have laws and
regulations in place and have not
demonstrated any commitment towards
invoking those regulations I see that as
a great betrayal of the labor that women
are contributing to those institutions
[Music]